i think you'll find this super
interesting
the term gaslighting has become very
tainted by a movement on the right to
claim
that the use of the term gaslighting is
in and of itself some kind of ruse now
the truth is that gaslighting is a real
thing
sometimes the word is applied correctly
and sometimes it isn't
but generally speaking gaslighting is a
form of psychological manipulation
in which a person or a group covertly
sows
seeds of doubt in a targeted individual
or group
making them question their own memory
perception or judgment
so simply lying about something telling
a lie
it doesn't really rise to the level of
being gaslighting
in spirit or or even by the letter of
what it is
there has to be some kind of more
calculated manipulative intent
and last night on his fox news program
host tucker carlson
casually claimed that he and his team
weren't able to find any evidence
that q anon and q even exist
or that they have a following or that
they're a thing and part of the reason
he says that he doesn't believe they
exist is that he didn't find an official
q a on website
which of course if you know anything
about q anon you would understand well
they don't have a website
uh if you haven't if somehow you're not
aware of q anon
i envy you q anon is a disproven
right-wing conspiracy theory
which claims that there's a secret cabal
of satan worshiping
pedophiles running a global child
sex trafficking ring and that they
plotted against donald trump
sometimes hillary is involved sometimes
not
and that donald trump was sent to be
president to root out these horrible
people
supporters of q anon include white
nationalists
and other far-right extremists and of
course they were major
supporters of donald trump and uh they
were big players in continuing to sow
the false stories of so-called voter
fraud and election fraud
in the time after the 2020 presidential
election now
the people who believe in this stuff and
support
trump through it definitely exist
they're obviously wrong on the facts but
tucker here says
we can't find any evidence that this is
even a thing and this
is a perfect example of gaslighting
let's take a look at the video
so it's worth finding out where the
public is getting all this false
information this disinformation as we'll
call it so we checked
we spent all day trying to locate the
famous q anon
which in the end we learned is not even
a website if it's out there we could not
find it
then we checked marjorie taylor green's
twitter feed because we have heard she
trafficks in disinformation seen and
told us
but nothing there so tucker learned
that q anon doesn't have a website
well we we knew that he says he couldn't
find
q anon nor any evidence of
disinformation
posted by marjorie taylor green ever
this is truly gaslighting first of all
you know the whole idea of cue from the
beginning was
they don't have a website there's no q
anon gazette there's no
q report equivalent of the drudge report
where they post their ideas and articles
the whole concept was this is a here's a
term
this is a subrosa thing where
there's supposedly an insider providing
the information
posting it to obscure internet forums
and it's
uh repeated or signal boosted by the
followers of
q so this is a red herring and it is
gaslighting tucker not finding a website
isn't evidence for or against anything
now mind you
tucker is the same guy who says
he mailed physical flash drives without
having backed up the content
across the country during his so-called
investigation of hunter biden
so he's not necessarily the brightest
guy when it comes to these
investigations
and informational security but okay now
the extra gas lighting
is tucker and fox news have actually
been major amplifiers
themselves of election related
disinformation which plays right into
the entire q perspective
and they're being sued at this point for
it for repeating
some of the same claims coming from the
q anon wing
of the republican party including that
donald trump actually won
the 2020 election now in terms of you
know the marjorie taylor green thing
he says we looked at marjorie taylor
green's twitter we didn't find any
disinformation ever
that's a laughable joke and she's
promoted cue stuff
for a very long time but you don't need
to go back very far
just look at the stuff she's posted over
the last 24 to 36 hours
this morning marjorie taylor green
tweeted quote
democrats are so beholden to the
abortion murder lobby
and their blood money campaign
contributions
that they nominate a guy becerra for
health and human services
who's fine with murdering babies up
until the day they are born
and maybe even after
that's not disinformation come on
and then also spreading disinformation
about january 6th
itself tweeting speaker pelosi have you
figured out who planted the pipe bombs
at the rnc in the dnc on january 5th
the night before the capital attack on
january 6
showing the attack was planned and not
incited by press
incited by president trump and directed
at
both republicans and democrats that's
just
the last 24 to 36 hours and she's been
spreading
and repeating q anon stuff for month
after month after month
this is gas lighting what tucker carlson
did is gaslighting
making his viewers question their
reality
maybe q anon doesn't even exist in
in which case by the way it would make
everything
that democrats are saying a lie which is
exactly the idea that populist tucker
carlson wants to promulgate on his
program
that's gaslighting and unfortunately
you have a really willing audience a
really eager audience to follow whatever
tucker carlson says on his program
remember tucker carlson's lawyers fox
news lawyers used when defending tucker
carlson in lawsuits
they used as a defense tucker carlson
shouldn't be
uh interpreted as telling the truth he's
doing hyperbole
and he's doing entertainment he's not
actually reporting facts on his program
that's what lawyers
said under oath uh not under oath uh in
in lawyers aren't under oath in court
proceedings
defending the statements of tucker
carlson just remember that when you
watch this program
today's show is sponsored by an
excellent audiobook
called takeover how a conservative
student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audiobook from noah feldman it
just came out
and feldman actually narrates the
audiobook himself
noah feldman of course is a harvard law
professor and constitutional
scholar you may remember him from his
prominent role in trump's impeachment
number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country six of the nine
current supreme court justices are
current or former members of the
federalist society
and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for
its relationship with american politics
the federalist
society is an organization anyone in my
audience
should be aware of and the audiobook has
a ton of excellent insight into it and
the role it plays
i really enjoyed listening to the
audiobook i think anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover by noah feldman the audiobook
is just 4.99 and you can get it at
davidpakman.com
takeover or wherever you buy
books